[Music]
now remember you can
go to dot co dot uk slash cheers to get
our christmas offer
12 weeks of the spectator for just 12
pounds a free bottle of pork roast
champagne the
champagne of winston churchill terms and
conditions apply
now in november the spectator published
a pro scottish
independence article it was the first in
a long time by andrew wilson
former member of the scottish parliament
with the snp he chairs the sustainable
growth commission the sgc is an snp
funded research unit to look into the
economics of an independent scotland
uh andrew wilson welcome to
the program here on spectator tv let me
start
is it still snp policy to continue
using the pound sterling outside of the
uk monetary union
for an unspecified period after
independence
thank you for having me on andrew it's
much appreciated i'm sorry i'm not
wearing as convivial a jumper
i will do next time and yes it is so
that the idea there is
to be honest about the transition that
will be needed
to move towards independence learning
all of the lessons from from brexit
really which is to state we know that in
doing so we wouldn't have sovereignty
over
monetary policy the bank of england's
independent anyway
but that is a price worth paying because
it mitigates the risks that would come
from moving too quickly
to a new currency and and that's the
reason for it so it's to have a a
managed and balanced
orderly transition obviously you don't
have monetary policy control
but we don't it presents so it's neutral
to what's happening at the moment
and what happens the day before
independence will happen the day after
it
and you focus on everything else getting
the government set up creating a central
bank
crucially appointing someone who is
credible in the view of the
world markets to lead the central bank
all of these things are
the priority but given that you accept
that you would not
have an independent monetary policy
in this transition period as
particularly as defined by the european
union
in that period you could not join the
european union
well the key is well what's what's
certainly true
is that it's a unique situation no one
has gone out and gone back in no one has
joined in
in these terms and in this way
scotland's been a member as part of the
united kingdom for 45 or more years
what their key says on on the matter of
currency or monetary policy is simply
that
member states should have should treat
their exchange rates as a matter of
common concern
what that really means of course is that
you don't use your exchange rate to
unfairly compete within the single
market and we wouldn't be doing that
whether or not
we're allowed to join in advance of of
having our own currency will really be a
matter for the european union
that's highly unlikely isn't it andrew
wilson i mean it's highly unlikely that
the european union
would allow you to join as opposed to
discuss joining even maybe do some
negotiations
go through the principles involved but
to a lawyer allow you to join
when you have the currency of a nation
whose exclusive policies to divert from
the eu
i mean i think we can both agree that
ain't gonna happen well we'll we'll see
i mean i think there is incentive for
the eu to have scotland back as a member
state we would like to join the whole
point of having
this argument at the moment is because
we're out the eu against our
uh expressed wishes i think we can um
but it will take time i mean it will
take you hold on andrew are you saying
that you could join the eu
yes with stalin yes i believe that we
can but this will be a matter not for me
not even for the scottish government
would be matter for you to to decide
but what possible evidence do you have
for that you're using the currency of a
country
that isn't even in the eu the eu has its
own currency but you don't want to
to use that you would not have an
independent central bank
as defined by the eu and what it demands
you wouldn't have an independent
monetary policy you wouldn't be setting
your own
interest rates i mean it's inconceivable
that you could join with sterling
well i i i don't think any of those
things are inconceivable in terms of
membership we would have our own central
bank it would be independent but it
wouldn't be setting interest rates or it
wouldn't be
ordering the the exchange rate and it
wouldn't have the power to print money
and it wouldn't be a lender of last
resort because you're not printing
and all of these are the conditions for
joining the eu
not just the eurozone their conditions
for being in the eu
well none of those things are actually
set out in the ikea's stands but
we would be a lender of last resort so
the central bank and its regulator would
be a lender of last resort to the
domestic scottish banks that would be
the case we would have a central bank
in which the way the euro member states
have their own central banks at present
it wouldn't have all the functions of
the bank of england
but this is the orderly way to do it
what the eu wouldn't want is for
scotland to be joining the eu
going through a disorderly process of
independence from the united kingdom
i think they would be much more
interested in in scotland having a
an economy which was stable which was
growing and that the institutions were
being set up in an
orderly manner so that's the plan that
we've we have we have recommended
to anything either in the key or
in european law or in statements by
senior european figures
that would indicate that you could join
the eu
with sterling as your currency well
there's no there's no precedent andrew
that much is true
no but if you buy anybody that said they
would do something unprecedented
but we're coming out of the the united
kingdom ireland did this the same way it
kept the united kingdom currency for a
period of six years albeit
a completely different era and then the
rules and then it was the european
economic
all i'm saying is that the precedent for
doing this was set by ireland
long ago there is no precedent for this
going into the european union of course
there isn't
but scotland is already um fully
compliant with
almost all of the requirements to be eu
member state we would need to set up
some institutions chiefly a central bank
i think would be a great counterparty
and an excellent um eu citizen state so
i i do believe
you may think of that but i know the eu
has to
agree that indeed and i can find no
indication i mean i look at even the
rules that they give for
a country like montenegro or others
coming in they've got to have
independent central banks ability to
print money
set their own interest rates all the
rest of it you will have none of that
these are important powers
that will stay with the bank of england
in this period yeah and i think it's
the orderly way to do it now whether or
not the european union accepts scotland
as a member remains to be seen
i believe they will that certainly is
going to be our intent as a country or
at least i hope it will
um and i think this is the best that the
alternative
is less orderly and it would probably
delay scotland's accession because it
would take
longer for scotland to properly create
the institutions and the stability that
we need
i'm not clear in in in any sense in
which you would be independent in this
period
uh your monetary policy would be sent by
the bank of england
uh and your currency would be set by
brussels because
as you say acqui uh the chapter 17 of
the aqui says that exchange rates are a
matter of
common concern so you'd have to run your
exchange
exchange rate uh in in line with the
european union but here's the problem
you don't control the exchange rate it's
sterling
so there's none of these areas do you
meet any of the criteria
well as i say you know we will only be
able to apply when we are
formally independent and that will take
time itself and after a vote maybe a
couple of years and then we can apply
and then we will see what the european
union
actually thinks and this is the orderly
way to go about it of course it's not
full independence but then
no countries in the world other than
north korea are fully independent
independence is about
interdependence and and sharing
sovereignty and that's the idea of the
european union andrew as you will
appreciate and know the policies i
understand it is this
this would be a transition stage to a
scottish currency
yeah how long would this transition be
well that depends we've we've set out uh
recommendations for a number of tests
that would then determine how quick it
would happen
we estimated well we estimated at that
point between five and ten years
key tests include financial stability
and the
ability to get your deficit into an
orderly place in line with the stability
pact
that will take time um but between five
or ten years it
could be could become before it could be
ten years
it could be ten it could be before
you're in a position to join the
european union
um well as i say i i disagree that it's
a block to joining and we will see
that's a matter for the eu but it could
indeed
take time i mean it's four years since
we voted for brexit at the united
kingdom level and we still don't know
what the arrangements are
i think it's important to be honest to
set out what the transition will look
like what the trade-offs are because
nothing's
free and easy this will not be a simple
thing to do the underlying message
andrew is that it will be worth it
but it would begin a a task of reform
that would take a generation to get to
the levels of performance we want the
whole point is to get to be
as well performing as countries like
denmark if we can over the course of a
generation but we
we we mustn't go a populist route we
mustn't take the approach of brexit
no transition no honestly we have to be
clear and i don't
see let's come on let's come on to
whether it's worth it in a minute but
just look at the time scale here because
it could take x years you know what x is
uh well you still have sterling before
you get to your scottish currency it
could then take
y years for that new currency to
establish itself a scottish central bank
to satisfy
the eu's requirements so x and y
together
could be more than 10 years it could be
a lot more indeed
it could not be for the foreseeable
future that's the reality
well we'll see i mean this can be
exercised in the the campaign should
should the referendum happen i i don't
agree i think it will happen much more
quickly i mean
east germany was able to join in months
when it unified with west germany
um it's possible that these things can
be done scotland has already a
sophisticated democracy
with a well-advanced economy who would
be a good member counterpart
east germany john because it immediately
took the euro you're not prepared to do
that
well they they they joined with the
german i'm trying to remember the timing
i don't think
no no they what i mean is they didn't
immediately take the euro what they
immediately took
the deutsche mark is their currency uh
which then transmuted into the euro
you're not proposing that no we're not i
mean this this proposal
is in our view the most orderly way to
achieve stability
it's not just the currency it's a
roadblock to you
joining the eu you need to meet the eu's
stability pack conditions and that
includes
deficits budget deficits below three
percent of gdp
uh now even before covert struck
scotland's deficit was almost nine
percent of gdp
so it would unless you want to slash
public spending immediately
it would take you years to get to the
stability packs conditions
well again we'll see what the starting
point looks like when we get when we get
to it because
the the fiscal position at the moment is
obviously unusual the stability pact is
suspended
and what's interesting is you don't have
to achieve the stability pack to join
i mean the priest isn't there croatia
and hungary were all
not performing to sustainability pack
deficit levels when they joined indeed
continue to not do for some time but
what definitely needs to happen is that
you have set
up your financial governance such that
you're on a glide path
to achieve it now interestingly at this
moment andrew
if you look at the imf statements in
their fiscal report in the autumn
they were arguing that countries
focusing on britain
shouldn't be built tightening too
quickly and as we come out the crisis
we need us to keep money flowing into
the economy both for
life support but also for stimulus and
then for reform so the priority for the
coming
five years or could be more must be to
invest and so i don't think normal
fiscal arrangements
apply but what's also true just now what
covert proves is that deficits of the
level you've just stated
can be funded at historically low levels
of interest migration got bombed away
the other week at 0.9 percent interest
now if croatia can get a bond away at
that level
so could scotland obviously there will
be risk premiums to manage down but i do
believe that it's fundable but
you're right we do need to get the
financial arrangements in order but your
own growth commission said it could take
up to 10 years to meet the stability tax
conditions
absolutely but remember that was pre
that the market conditions that we have
at the moment and obviously prequel but
there will be a
return to prudence andrew wilson at some
stage that that is
eu policy of course we're going through
an unusual time but the stability pack
will come back in
by the time you are ready to negotiate
this and you will have to meet its
conditions
and we do and write and sing we set that
out what i'm saying the one point of
disagreement with you
is that um you need to get
over the stability point to get in i
think the president's there that you
don't but you do need to be getting
it towards it in an orderly fashion over
time i think and i think the key way to
get
deficit round down around the world is
by focusing on growth i think
austerity or cutting spending or indeed
increasing facts
at this moment in these times would be
counterproductive and wouldn't achieve
what they were
they said your commission said you had
to get public spending down as a
percentage of gdp
that was the method we set out which as
we decided in the report
well that's a reduction in overall
spending as a percentage of the economy
but not not in cash terms but what we
were saying at that point andrew was
to to demonstrate a conservative and
prudent approach
we didn't decide to model and i just
assumed that growth was going
above trend and therefore everything
would be easy because we were
demonstrating
we could do this without getting growth
up what i'm saying to you now i think
that the lesson for the coming five
years is the priority for government
intervention on fiscal policy must be to
stimulate growth
and investment so that we can both get
out of the pandemic crisis but through
the reform era that comes next
deal with climate change deal with the
great harms that are happening at the
moment not least inequality
and back to the core point why do we
want to do this because the united
kingdom's economic performance
has not served um anyone over a very
long period but now more than before
it's twice
as bad performance as the average for
the industrialized world this year on
on the measures of the oecd so so the
united kingdom is both not performing
economically but also
has one of the worst inequality records
in europe as well
well you are assuming some pretty
reasonable growth figures to try and get
your budget deficit
done i mean you're assuming average
growth higher than it's
been in scotland in the past decade you
also make some pretty heroic
uh spending assumptions but on the
growth i want to ask you this
i mean you think you're on the record of
saying brexit's a
serious setback to british economic
growth because of all the trade friction
it will introduce even with a deal but
in your own projections you don't allow
for the same serious bet
setbacks of trade friction for an
independent scotland
well i i think the the point here is
that getting back into the european
union would be pro-growth
back into the single market and
customers union would be good for growth
setting up the institutions of
government in scotland which we
currently pay
to have in london would be growth so
these are all reasons to be optimistic
but only 20 of your exports go to the eu
60
go to the rest of the uk that's where
first of all you will still be out of
the eu for quite a while
so you'll still have trade friction
there and then if you get independence
you'll have even more trade friction
with the market to which you sell
60 of your exports you're right though
earlier in the interview you were saying
we wouldn't get into the eu for a period
of time and so there would be no change
to the trading arrangements
either with europe or indeed with the uk
we will see what the friction looks like
with the border to our east and to our
west that is being imposed
we think by january and we'll see what
the situation is there
that is a trade-off you are correct to
identify that that is a trade-off
we have to judge as a country whether
it's worth it i believe that all the
evidence is
you can look to ireland as a great
example um of countries who join the
european union
small countries who are able to succeed
on a bigger stage
and we can cooperate in that way and and
grow faster
if you say that all our eggs have to be
in the basket of trading just with the
rest of the uk
which is why i'm not so i'm not saying
that but i'm putting this to
you because i don't understand the
answer about 45
of uk exports go to the eu and you think
brexit a disaster for what that will do
because of trade friction
but 60 of scottish exports go to the
rest of the uk
by definition that's potentially an even
bigger disaster
it must be well sorry i did try to
answer that i mean the point is that to
begin with
um for a period until we join the
european union there will be no change
to the arrangements on on trade
when we join the european union then
whatever the arrangements that are
agreed between the united kingdom and
europe
will be what the arrangement is between
scotland and the united kingdom we don't
know yet and we remain that's why we
didn't in our report
include it because even now four years
when we still don't know what the
arrangements exactly will be i don't
believe
um i don't believe it will be the sort
of transition that you're
talking about i mean if you even just
pick another area canada has 85
of its exports going into the united
states they have an arrangement
they are independent you don't have to
be part of the same country to trade
with obviously
no i understand but it's also reasonably
friction free borders
as well but you could then be in a
choice where you
you may get a benefit of less trade
friction with the eu but by far your
biggest market and it still will be
by then you're going to increase the
trade uh friction that would be an
incentive not to join the eu but stay in
the uk
well again as i say we will know what
that will look like when we see what the
border is
and we will see what the level of
friction is
if the level of friction is severe are
you seriously saying
that you might then not decide to join
the eu
but stay in some kind of economic union
with the uk
well i would i would hope not to have
any friction in any direction that would
be in the interest of all parties
well that's not going to happen you know
the united kingdom seems determined on
on a different course at present but we
will see
so there ain't no we will vote when we
come to a vote we'll know this trade-off
will be clear but they'll be living and
breathing on
on the border to our east and our west
so we'll be able to see it
you're going to be in a situation where
you're going to have the currency of
another country so you will have very
limited
monetary policy you will be trying to
get towards the eu rules which mean a
huge squeeze
on public spending your party has ruled
out major tax rises because you
frightened all the caravans head
south whichever way you cut it on fiscal
monetary policy tax policy the first 10
years of an independent scotland are
going to be a decade of austerity
well absolutely absolutely not i mean i
think that would be entirely
counterproductive
and the wrong strategy to take and if f
scotland doesn't
choose independence then we will have
fiscal policy set by governments we
don't vote for
and the record of the conservatives in
the last 10 years has been one of
austerity which has led to outcomes
which are bad for scotland
and indeed for the regions and nations
of the rest of the uk
the whole point of independence is to
say would we be more likely or less
likely
to choose policies that suit scotland if
we had a government that we voted for
every time
this is a core economic and democratic
point
it's true andrew you might say that you
think that scotland would get it wrong
the evidence of history i'm not saying
get it wrong i'm looking at the position
in which it would find itself even if
you've got a new council
it'll take a long while to establish the
bonafides of that new currency the
currency markets will be tough
on you the bond markets will not be keen
to lend very much and if they do it'll
be a premium
uh because you're a new kid on the block
of the currency brussels will say
you've got to get your fiscal deficit
down you've got to cut spending here
you've got to get that
budget deficit much closer to three
percent you've got to align
your currency with the euro it's all in
equity 7
chapter 17 of the aqui they the markets
brussels london they will force all
sorts of things in
on you you will have very little room
for maneuver
independence would be a chimera well
we've got no room for a maneuver at
present so it will be
a transition from constraints where we
are just now with limited evolution
to independence as part of the european
union you're right to say
that there are trade-offs you're right
to say that there will be challenges
to be overcome and we will have to see
these set out clearly in a transition
plan
we never got one from i mean you say you
haven't got room for maneuver but at the
moment
you are able to take in per capita
a little lower than the british avenue
british average when it comes to tax
revenue
and you get a massively more than the
british average when it comes to
spending
uh your deficit is financed by the union
at the moment
well let's move to a situation where you
have to finance your own deficit
well if we pause on that for a minute i
mean the money that's raised in scotland
in taxation
pays for the equivalent of the entire
scottish government budget plus all the
welfare
plus all the pensions the deficit to
which you refer is really made up of uk
programs uk debt
interest defense and other spending
areas which
would have to pay for defense you've
committed to joining nato that's two
percent of gdp
and you would have to pay a share of
british debt interest you still have to
pay that of your independence
absolutely the point i'm trying to
understand well
the point i'm trying to make is that
it's not money coming over the border to
boost the scottish economy this is money
that's
not spent but as allocated against
scotland we set out in that report
how we address it and how we deal with
it we i do agree that we should pay
a portion of uk debt interest and we set
out again in the report
that we would pay an annual solidarity
payment from scotland to the rest of the
uk
because what's interesting if you look
at the balance sheet of united kingdom
government
there are many more liabilities than
assets on it about four trillion and
growing on the liabilities
two and a half trillion of assets so the
negotiation between scotland and the
discussion between scotland
and the uk government would be one of
what responsibilities did scotland take
not what
benefits right with this 15 billion
deficit
what would you not be spending on that
is currently spent now
well the markets at the moment aren't
punishing
any member state of the european union
in the way that you say that they would
scotland
i didn't ask for the marks i'm saying
what would you not be spending on
that is currently spent now you've
admitted you'd have to
contribute to the debt service uh of the
residual uk you've admitted you could
still spend money on defense
may be different from how it's done now
but you still do that where would you
not spend
well that'll be a matter for the for the
government at the time to choose on the
basis of their their electoral promises
to the people
we have set out in the report that
you've clearly read in detail
um some areas where we would definitely
know defense is one where we would spend
less than the united kingdom does as a
share of
gdp there will be others you still have
to spend two percent
to join nato well you know that
most of the nato members don't don't
have two percent i mean there are only
three or four of them you're the new kid
on the block they'll want you to commit
to two
well the eu will ask you to commit at
least in principle to the euro
what the european union what the other
international institutions will want to
see from scotland
is that it's transitioning in an orderly
way that it's respectful of its
responsibilities to the rest of the uk
not least in debt interest
but in other areas but it takes
seriously common defense challenges
all of these things is what we were as
what scotland was required to set out so
i hope you
think i don't have no idea what you're
going to cut
well to make any kind of ink road into
that 15 billion pound
deficit but so the point again we
covered a few
minutes ago the point of the moment is
even the imf are arguing that countries
should not be cutting
to reduce their deficits for the
foreseeable future the priority should
be on investing for growth
and then the imf is talking about
countries with established
uh currencies with a long track record
of borrowing
and not defaulting and with independent
central banks
and with the ability to print money none
of that applies
to an independent scholar i don't
understand why you
are referring all of the time to the
ability to print money because there is
no evidence in economic history that
monetary policy or the ability to print
money
is a route to economic growth and
success it can buy
time to stabilize during times of crisis
or fluctuations
but if qe and printing money was the
route to success britain would be the
the best performing economy and japan
would be the second best
neither of those are true in truth
over time the focus of economic policy
should be on growth
productivity and over time and and being
honest about the fact that changing
information takes a generation
the reason i mentioned printing money is
because i see an increasing number of
snp supporters
saying that budget problems as debts are
all that could be sold by a reference to
modern
monetary theory which is the printing of
money basically
you accept that that's incompatible with
eu membership
100 percent i accept that and it's one
of the things which is um
but just funnily enough looking at the
key to which you were referring
and central you know the the the um
monetary financing of of the government
by the central bank
is not allowed so mmt is a theory
which i think would be a colossal error
for any country right now
but certainly for a new country like
scotland but some of the
rising forces in your party a chap
called tim ryder
he's been promoting it another chap
called chris hanlon
he is now your uh snp policy computer
they're all pushing this
well it's people are allowed in
political parties to take differing
points of view on different things the
key to setting policy are you not really
at the center of setting policy anymore
um well all i've done is produce a
report with with members of the
commission some of whom are now
uh cabinet secretaries and that is the
party policy now people can promote mmt
it is a thing that's alive in the world
that's adherents are
are almost religions religious in their
zeal um
it could be it could be possible maybe
in america
maybe in china it's not possible for a
small country the final question to you
that
if if if you are still setting
uh the the direction of policy in this
for the snp
chris hanlon as i said you're you're snp
policy convener now
who is pro modern monetary theory the
printing of money
he says you should take no share of
national debt
at all he even accepts that the
financial services industry in scotland
which is large
will decline and his comment on that was
and good riddance to it now
are you is that the serious words of a
serious party
that is going to have to establish its
financial bone feedies
well it's not the party's policy or
position andrew i mean
everything is the policy convener for
every political party you could
pick individuals who hold posts at
whatever level and find things that
don't agree with the party
it is not it's not what's in the report
it won't be what's in the white paper
for a referendum it won't be what the
scottish government does
and of course the financial services
sector is hugely important scotland
employing
attendance so not a quite the opposite
we would want to be
a home for physical services and in
actual fact going back into the european
union
the ability for for companies and asset
management and other
areas of finance and pensions and so on
there would be an attraction to being
located in scotland rather than
out with the european union okay we'll
leave it there andrew wilson we thank
you for your time
and going through all these complicated
issues with you it's a fascinating
discussion
and a very merry christmas to you and to
[Music]
you
[Music]
you